imaginez-vous plus de 2000 personnes
réunies dans cette cour des grandes
écuries du roi à versailles
ajoutez à cela les meilleurs cavaliers
mondiaux et vous obtiendrez l'un des
tournois les plus prestigieux de cette
année 2010 est en france le jumping
international 5 étoiles a été présenté
officiellement aujourd'hui dans la cité
royale en présence des organisateurs des
sportifs et de l'acteur guillaume canet
ambassadeurs de l'événement
l'idée de ramener le cheval à l'endroit
du cheval de l'époque de louis xiv et
bien sûr qu'on pourrait ici ne faire
qu'un concours prestigieux en ramenant
l'excellence déjà il ya une curiosité
d'avoir envie de voir un peu ce lieu et
ce cadre et puis et puis valeurs du
spectacle parce qu'il ya des meilleurs
cavaliers mondiaux ça va ça va aller
vite et haut
parmi les têtes d'affiché françaises on
retrouvera notamment le champion
olympiques 2016 kevin staut originaire
du chéné mon grand père paternel habiter
ici je venais très régulièrement dans
mon enfance
ensuite une fierté pour l'équitation
française arrivée aujourd'hui organisé
un concours de cinq étoiles donc nue
plus haut niveau ici dans un lieu
mythique dans les écuries du roi c'est
extraordinaire du 4 au 7 mai vers cei va
avoir des allures de centres équestres
géant de son chevaux seront visibles
dans les rues de la commune
on veut aussi faire partager aux
versaillais aux gens de la région
ce qu'est notre sport on a en a la
chance aujourd'hui de s'appuyer sur une
équipe championne olympique et qu'on va
présenter aux gens le prix des places
sera annoncé le 7 mars le même jour que
le lancement officiel du site internet
du concours